In the previous video, we saw
that the mandible, or jawbone,
received the highest dose out of
all of the critical structures.
The mean mandible
dose was 11.3 gray.
So how can we reduce this?
One approach is to modify
our objective function.
Our current objective
is to minimize
the sum of the total dose
to each critical structure.
So we're minimizing the sum of
the total dose to the brain,
plus the total dose
to the brain stem,
plus a total dose
to the spinal cord,
plus the total dose
to the parotid glands,
to the mandible.
We could instead
change our objective
to make the total dose to
the mandible more important.
This can be done by weighting
the term for the mandible.
By giving the mandible
dose a weight of 10,
the total dose to the mandible
becomes 10 times more important
in our objective
than the total dose
to the other
critical structures.
If we solve our problem
with this new objective,
we get the solution
shown in this figure.
The dose to the tumor, shown as
the red line, does not change.
It still stays within the
constraints we've defined.
For each of the
critical structures,
the solution with the
previous objective
is shown as a dotted
line, and the new solution
with the weighted objective
is shown as a solid line.
We can see that the dose to
the mandible, shown in blue,
has significantly
decreased by adding
a weight in the objective.
However, the dose to
other critical structures
has increased, especially to the
parotid glands, shown in black,
and to the spinal
cord, shown in green.
This shows how you can
modify the objective
to capture different trade-offs
that might be desirable
to different decision-makers
or for different patients.
Another way to
explore trade-offs
is to modify the constraints.
For example, by relaxing
the mandible maximum dose
constraint or by allowing the
maximum dose to the mandible
to be higher, we may improve
our total healthy tissue dose.
We would like to know how
much the objective changes
for different constraints.
This can be answered by
looking at the shadow
prices of the constraints.
Recall that we have a constraint
limiting the total dose
for each voxel in each
critical structure.
This table shows the highest
shadow price for any one voxel
in each critical structure.
The parotid glands and the brain
stem have shadow prices of 0.
This means that we're not
even giving the maximum amount
of radiation allowed
to these structures,
so modifying the constraints
is not beneficial.
The spinal cord has a
shadow price of 96.911.
This means that by
increasing the radiation
to one voxel of the
spinal cord by one unit,
we can decrease
the total radiation
to other critical
structures by 96.9 units.
The mandible has the highest
shadow price of 7,399.72.
So if a slight increase in the
mandible dose to a single voxel
is acceptable, the total healthy
tissue dose can be reduced.
Keep in mind that this
is the total reduction
across all voxels
in the objective.
We've seen in this video that by
modifying the formulation, both
the objective and
the constraints,
we can explore different
trade-offs in our problem.